how special is the human brain in this
full context of biology yeah I mean look
there's no getting away from the fact
that the human brain allows us to do
things that we could not do without it
you can say the same thing about the
liver
yeah
this is this is true and so and so you
know I I my goal is not no you're right
my goal is just being polite to the
brain right now well looking a
politician like listen everybody has
everybody has a role yeah and it's very
important role that's right we have to
acknowledge the importance of the brain
you know there are more than enough
people who are um cheerleading the the
brain right so so I I don't feel like uh
nothing I say is going to reduce
people's excitement about the human
brain and so so I I emphasize other
languages I don't think it gets too much
credit I think other things don't get
enough credit I think the brain is is
the human brain is incredible and
special and all that I think other
things need more credit and and I also
think that
this and I'm sort of this way about
everything I don't like binary
categories but almost anything I like a
Continuum and the thing about the human
brain is that it by by accepting that as
as some kind of an important category or
essential
um essential thing we end up with all
kinds of weird pseudo problems and
conundrum so for example
uh when we talk about it you know if you
don't want to talk about
um uh uh ethics and other other things
like that uh and and what you know this
this idea that surely if we look out
into the universe surely we don't
believe that this human brain is the
only way to be sentient right surely we
don't you know and to have high level
cognition I just I can't even wrap my
mind around this this idea that that is
the only way to do it no doubt there are
other architectures made made of
completely different principles that
achieve the same thing and once we
believe that then that tells us
something important it tells us that
things that are not quite human brains
or chimeras of human brains and other
tissue or human brains or other kinds of
brains and novel configurations or
things that are sort of brains but not
really or plants or or embryos or
whatever might also have important
cognitive status so that's the only
thing I think we have to be really
careful about treating the human brain
as if it was some kind of like sharp
binary category you know you are or you
are aren't I I don't believe that exists